[موسيقى]
العنف الاسري جائحه مسكوت عنها تهز اركان
ربع الاسر في بعض دول العربيه
عينيها على يد زوجها فداء لاولادها اما
نهيله فتسبقها دموعها وهي تقص علينا
معاناتها مع عنف زوجها والتي تزايدت مع
جائتك حتى اقدم على احراقها نجفي اعجوبه
لكنها مكلومه للابد
في قصتنا العرب والعنف الاسري نرصد
بالارقام بعضا من مؤشرات هذا العنف دول
عربيه مختلفه وحتى عالميا ونحاول استقراء
اراء خبراء عن مدى ارتباطه بالاوضاع
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه والسياسيه ونستكمل
بقيه القصه مع اسيل العلائي مديره قسم
التواصل والاعلام في شبكه البارومتر
العربيه البحثيه في جامعه البرنسون
والناشطه في الشؤون الجندريه وهكذا
الدكتور حسين الخزاعي البروفيسور المتخصص
في علم الاجتماع نسال الوظيفينا عن رؤيتهم
لاسباب تزايد معدلات العنف الاسري في
العالم العربي وتاثيره على بنيه المجتمع
وكيف يمكن تقديم الدعم لضحايا وما السبل
الممكنه للحد منها محيطكم علما المشاهدين
ان بعض الشهادات والقصص المؤلمه قد لا
تتحملها الفئات المرحفه لكنها للاسف تحكي
سوا
لفئات المستضعفه نعود للحوار لكن المشاهد
القصص اولا
القصه اللي عندي مش عندي لحالي بالمجتمع
اللي عندنا نحن موجود كثير
ما في حاجه ما في شارع ما في بنايه الا ما
فيها عم يصير فيها اذا شيء
وضع الاتصال
وقعت عام 2020 جرائم عده هزت الرايه
العامه العربي بسبب وحشيتها
من رمى الطفليها في نهر دجله
مجموعه قامت بتقطيع يدي الفتى الصالح
حمدان طفله قاصر تعرضت للاغتصاب واحرقت
وهي حيه
[موسيقى]
رجل 40
بالحاله الاجتماعيه مرتبط بالظرف السياسي
الظرف الاقتصادي الاشكاليه الكبيره انه
نحنا بالمنطقه العربيه دائما امام عنف
مرتفع مختلف متطور ولكن يختلف بتسميته
وبظروفه
وبالحديث عن العنف لا يمكن اغفال قضيه
شائكه وهي قضيه العنف الاسري لما لها من
خصوصيه وكونها ظاهره مسكوته عنها في
العالم العربي وهنا نستعرض قصتنائل الذي
قرر بعد 20 عاما ولاول مره ان يروي لنا ما
تعرض له من عنف من قبل والده وهو يعتقد
انه بذلك قد يساهم بتوعيه اخرين حول مخاطر
هذه الظاهره التي يعيش طبيعتها حتى اليوم
بعد ما خلصت الحرب 92 تقريبا كل عمره كان
على الجبهات وبالحرب وبالاحزاب
كان يجي على البيض احيانا بدون سبب بدون
ما تطلبي منه شيء اذا هو كان معصب بدك
تنضربي اذا بدك تنامي بره
نحن ما كان ياخذنا لعند الدكتور او يجيب
لنا دواء
يعني طلعنا يوقفنا برا لتنزل حرارتنا
انا اصعب قصه من ايديك الفتره المعلم فيه
يعني ما بنساها
هي مره كنت عم بلعب انا واخي بيطلع سقطنا
بنختلف نحن ونقدر بعض يعني وصلت على البيت
هيك بدي دق على الباب
قبلته مفتوح
طلعت لجوه على البيت ما في حدا
هدوء ما في صوت كانه اهلي مش في البيت
انا فتحت الباب وغرقته وبابا وين قاعد على
التتخيط مخبي لي فوق
انا سكرت الباب
[موسيقى]
يفوتني على المطبخ
يخبطني
يكون حاطط بالارض بس معبيه مي يو
بحط رجلي هيك و راسي يبلش ينزلني بالدرس
ويطلعني ينزل لي راسي وطلعوا بالميك
[موسيقى]
يخلص هاي يحملني ينقل على الكرسي على
الصلاه
من ايام الحرب محتفظ فيه
يعني انا شي سبع مرات معذب انا وصغير على
الكهرباء
احنا هظهر مكان فيكي تحكي بس كبرنا بتحكي
لتوقع حدا
بتمنى بيغلط يتحاسبوا بيصير فينا نعيش
بامان يعني الطفل مظلوم
بالنسبه للمفاهيم الاجتماعيه
من العنف الاسري حتى هذه الاوانين وان
كانت امنت جزء من الحمايه ولكن قاصره كانت
انه تؤدي الحمايه المطلوبه ولم يعد هناك
في تعميم للفكره حتى المؤنث يقدر يحكي
فكلما زاد الوعي بهذا الموضوع كلمه ذات
الضغط لتطويل القوانين ولا سد النقص
وبالعكس صارت اكثر الناس المشرفه على هذه
التحقيقات تملك هذه المعرفه فهيد بصير
التطوير يؤدي دوره
نحنا امام حاله اقتصاديه صعبه فطبعا سوف
تزيد الجريمه وسوف ياخذ العنف اوجه متعدده
لذلك انا بقول كل ما يرتبط الموضوع
بتركيبه الانسان وبحيته المجتمعيه كل ما
العنف راح ياخذ اوجه اشكال اخرى اذا ما
كان في وعي وفي قوانين راضعه صارمه سوف
يزداد وبطرق مختلفه
العربيه فان ربع الاسري في بعض الدول
ينتشر فيها العنف وتظهر الارقام ان للمراه
نصيب الاكبر من نسبه العنف الاسري في
العالم العربي
توجهنا الى الاردن في احدى مناطق الشمال
لمقابله فاطمه ابو عكليك عاند فاطمه من
العنف الزوجي سنوات عده ولكنها لم تتوقع
ان تفقد بصرها الى الابد على يدي شريكها
تروي لنا فاطمه تفاصيل ما جرى معها ليله
الحادثه
هذه
لاني كنت حردانه بسببها عند اهلي
نمنا يوم الحادثه ما فيش اي خلاف
وبالليل صحاني
اعمل له فنجان قهوه
رحت عملت له الطلبه
غرفه الضيوف
فجاه هو قام وسكر الباب بالمفتاح ورجع قعد
مكان وسحب السكينه
هجم علي حاول يقتلني اكثر من مره وكنت
ادافع عن حالي يعني الدفاع عن حال اني
دزوا عني يعني بس
رقم على منطقه الفحم بتاع الارجيله
اخذه اهجم فيه علي
صار يخنق فيه
خنقني هيك لورا وشد شعري للوراء
تترجى فيهم ويخليني عايشه ولا تقلعش عيوني
بدي اشوف بنتي واربيه
رد حط اصابع بعيني اليسار
وحاول يطلعها
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الاردن على خلفيه الحادثه تقول فاطمه
محاميتها جنبها ساعدها على تخطي محنتها
في ناس بتقول لعيونك يا فاطمه الهدف منها
هذه الحمله كم اولا تضامن والتضامن مع
الضحايا كثير مهم مع الناجيات كثير مهم
هذا الموضوع بعدين الهدف كمان انه نوصل
صوتنا لصاحب القرار نوصل صوتنا للناس
فاطمه هي واحده من ملايين ضحايا العنف على
النساء في السنوات الماضيه فقد صدر في
ابريل 2020 عن موقع يو ان ومن
243 مليون امراه وفتاه حول العالم تعرضنا
للعنف في العام 2019 اما في العام 2020
ومع تفشي رائحه كورونا وفرض اجراءات الحجر
فقد تفاقمت هذه الظاهره مما دفع الامين
العام للامم المتحده لتوجيه نداء الى جميع
الدول
وفي هذا الاطار ماذا تقول اذا عن ارقام
العنف في الاردن خلال الجائحه
الى منظمه الامم المتحده الى المراه
والمجلس الاقتصادي والاجتماعي في الاردن
وكانت هي مبنيه كمان على استبيان بالتعاون
مع مركز الدراسات الاستراتيجيه بالجامعه
الاردنيه مبين انه اه من وجهه نظر الناس
العنف زاد كمان اداره حمايه الاسره
اعلانات انها نسبه الشكاوى العنف زادت
بنسبه 33% خلال فتره الحظر اي ازمه
لواجهها المجتمع اي جائحه بدنا نعرف انه
هي اثرها راح يكون مضاعف على الفئات
الضعيفه اما في لبنان فقد اطلقت جمعيه
ابعاد حملات عده لتوعيه النساء خلال
الجائحه فكيف تقيم ممثله الجمعيه مدى
استجابه النساء لها
دي اول ابريل لاحظنا ازدياد باعداد حالات
العنف يلي عم تورد على الخط الامن لابعاد
وهذا الشيء خلينا نطلع على الارقام ونعمل
مقارنه الاعداد الاقتصاديه الي كنت عم
ترضن بنفس الفتره زمنيه بين 2019 و2020
ولاحظنا نسبه ارتفاع لحد 60% او حتى قوى
الامن الداخلي رصدت ارتفاع بنسبه 100% او
اكثر بعد الاوقات همم لانه كمان صار في
حملات مشابهه من ابر الهيئه الوطنيه لشؤون
المراه وقوى الامن الداخلي لحتى دواووا
على اهميه دعم النساء بخلال فتره جائحه
كرونه بناء على توصيات منظمه الصحه
العالميه والتقارير اللي كانت عم ترد
والوضع كان بلبنان انه كمان شاهدنا ارتفاع
بنسبه جرائم قتل ضد النساء لشهر ابريل
2020 رصدنا 20 حاله بس بشهر واحد لم ترتفع
الارقام وفي الاردن ولبنان فقط في فلسطين
مثلا اكثر من 25 امراه وفتاه قتل النعامه
20 في الجزائر اكثر من 39 جريمه قتل طالت
الجزائريات منذ بدايه العام 2020 اما في
مصر فقد شهد شهر يوليو من عام 2020 على
الاعتداءات وصلت الى احدى و50 جريمه ضد
النساء وفي المغرب سجلت نسبه العنف
الزوجيه ارتفاعا وصل الى 84 فاصل اربعه في
المئه خلال الجائحه وهنا قبلنا نهيله سيد
عشرينيه ناجيه من تعنيف زوجها التي ازداد
في فتره الحجر حتى وصل الى درجه احراقها
معامله دي لونها ورديه ومع اخوتي
في الدار ديالنا
بواحدف لمده تكون قد يعنفني بزاف يومها
حسب المجال حسب
فلوس الحليب
[موسيقى]
حسيت ولا ايه بالجماعه
اثنين
العروبيه النهارده
[موسيقى]
فيديو مقطع صدق
انا اصلا كبير
العنف بجميع اشكاله ظاهره لابد من
مواجهتها وهذا لا يمكن ان يتحقق دون تضافر
جهود الحكومات والمنظمات الحقوقيه
والمؤسسات المجتمعيه لتشريع القوانين
المناسبه والعمل على تطبيقها وعلى نشر
ثقافه الوعي للحد من استخدام العنف في
العلاقات الانسانيه
[موسيقى]
العنف الاسري ليس قاصرا على المجتمعات
العربيه فهو معضله عالميه تزيدت حدتها في
الواقع خلال الجائحه كورونا التي احدثت
حسب تقرير لمنظمه اوكسام عاصفه شامله من
القلق الاجتماعيه
وفقا تقرير الذي رصد العنف الاسري في 10
دول فانه حدث في الواقع ارتفاع في اعداد
البلاغات الوارده لاداره حمايه الاسر من
العنف البدني والجنسي بالنسبه ثلاثه
وثلاثين بالمئه خلال الاشهر الاولى من
جائحه كورونا وذلك في عده دول ومع
الاغلاقات التي شهدتها تشير دراسه في
الواقع لمنظمه الصحه العالميه الى ان
امراه واحده من كل ثلاث نساء اي حوالي 736
مليون امراه تتعرض اثناء حياتها للعنف
البدني او الجنسي من قبل الشريك كما تشير
الى ان سبعه وثلاثين في المئه من النساء
اللاتي يعشنا في البلدان الاشد فقرا قد
تعرضنا بالفعل للعنف البدني او الجنسي
تضيف ايضا ان ما بين 21% الى 23% من
النساء في شمال اوروبا اوروبا الغربيه
ايضا يتحرضنا لعنفي الشريك على مدى حياتهم
اشارت تقديرات الى ان عدد يصل الى مليار
الطفل في المرحله العمريه ما بين عامين
وسبعه عشر عاما يكون قد تعرضوا بها في
بدنيا او جنسيا او وجداني اوانه من
الاهمال اذا عدنا الان الى بلداننا
العربيه فقط كان لافتا ان الذكور يتعرضون
ايضا للاسف للعنف الاسري ايضا وفق استطلاع
للبارامتر العربي اجري في 11 دوله وهو ما
تؤكده في الواقع دراسه المحليه وديت فيه
بلدان متلمسها والمغرب والعراق
[موسيقى]
ارحبوا مجددا بضيفينا الكريمين في هذه
الحلقه من فيرجينيا بالولايات المتحده
اسيل العلائلي مديرته قسم التواصل
والاعلان في شبكه البارومتر العربي
البحريه في جامعه البرنسون والناشطه في
شؤون الجندريه ومن عمان الدكتور حسين
الخزاعي البروفيسور المتخصص في علم
الاجتماع اهلا بضيفين الكريمين حتى لنكون
متحيزين دعينا همم نبدا سيدتي الكريمه
سيده اسيل بالدكتور حسين الخزاعي دكتور
يعني قصص مؤلمه همم اتبعناها الليل يوجد
للاسف منها الكثير في مختلف المجتمعات
العربيه التي يفترض ان تحكمها قيام
التسامح الرحمه التالف والسؤال ما الذي
يفسر هذه المستويات من النوع من العنف
الاسري والمجتماعيه
شكرا الك وبارك الله فيكم وبمسي على كل
اللي بيسمعونا عبر كافه قطار الوطن العربي
وفي العالم اللي بيتابعوا قناه الجزيره
طبعا الاسباب كثيره
جدا
وخليني يعني اوضح قضيه اكثر
اماما واكثر حزنا واكثر شده على المواطن
العربي لما بيسمع انه صار فيه عنف بالاسره
الاسره هي التي توفر الامن والامان
والطمانينه والمحبه والموده بين افرادها
فالان لما هذه الاسره بدلا من ان توفر هذه
الاجواء توفر اجواء صاخبه اجواء عنف اجواء
اذى اجواء
فهذا هي الصدمه والصدمه عندما تكون عندنا
هذه
السلوك العنيفه في اقطار الوطن العربي
الاقطار اللي دائما هاي يعني الديانات
السماويه كلها تركز على كرامه الانسان
وعلى سعاده الانسان وعلى محبه الانسان اما
انه نحن نخالف تعاليم الدين واحكام الدين
ومنطلقات الدين فهذه الخطوره فالاسباب هنا
تبدا اولا همم في الفهم الخاطئ
الدين او التفسير الخاطئ او الجهل بتعليم
الدين عندما نوظف نحن عندما نريد ان نوظف
الدين لغرض شخصي وعندما نسيء الى الدين
الدين لا ينادي بالضرب ولا يطالب بالضرب
ولا يطالب بالاذى على العكس التعريف
الديني التعريف الديني للعنف بانه الاذى
فلا يجوز على الاطلاق تمسك او ان نقرا
الدين حرفيا او سطريا بانه طالب بالضرب لا
هذا الكلام خلينا نحكي كالتالي غير دقيق
وهذا لا يجوز ان نتمسك في ايه واحده فقط
لكن هناك عده نقاط يعني في الواقع نعم
الدكتور حسين هناك يتحدث عن الجانب الديني
بالفعل ويتخذ وكذريعه لكن هناك ايضا ما
يتحدث عن المجتمعات ذكوريه تلعب فيها
العادات والتقاليد التي لا تمد اطلاقا
بصلا الدين بهذا الموضوع ايضا نهيك عن
المشاكل النفسيه والاجتماعيه والاقتصاديه
وحتى السياسيه التي تمنعكس على الافراد
بهذه الطريقه
اللي ينفسه عن حاله الاحباط العامه التي
يعيشونها في المجتمعاتنا
انا اتفق معك تمام الاتفاق وشكرك ولكن هذا
سبب خليني احكي مهم جدا لا يجوز ان نقفله
بنروح الان للثقافه المجتمعيه العربيه هي
ثقافه ذكوريه وهذه الثقافه للاسف الشديد
تعزز العنق حتى لو كان هناك قوانين وحتى
لو كان هناك انظمه وكان هناك تعليمات كلها
اقطار الوطن العربي عندها قوانين ناظمه
لمواجهه العنف الاسري ولكن شوف الارقام
وبالمناسبه خليني اصلح رقم
هانت لما تحدثوا عن ربع الاسر العربيه
تعاني من العنف هذا الرقم المعلن عنه هذا
ولا النساء اللواتي بلغنا عنهم
شكرا لك هذا الوضع الخطير جدا
بانه 80 الى 90 بالميه لا يبلغن لماذا لا
يبلغن هنا الثقافه العربيه الخطيره التي
تعزز العنف تبدا اولا من ال ال ال ال
الدرجه الاولى من الزواج من ليله الزواج
واسمحيلي خليني اوجه كلمه لكل النساء اللي
بيسمعوني وخاصه للامهات الام في ليله
الزواج
تنصح ابنتها على التحمل تنصح ابنتها على
الصبر بان لا تعود مطلقه او حردان بالعربي
زعلانه تتحمل الزوج هنا الثقافه للاسف
الشديد
الاجتماعيه مهمه في كثير الاحيان عدوه
المراه تكون المراه نفسها للا شديد دعني
اتحول واسمع الى صوت المراه هنا في
البرنامج مع السيده اسيل العلائي انتم في
البارونات العربي اجايتهم في الواقع
استطلاع عن همم
لسنتي
2018/2019 كان هذا قبل الجائحه بعد
الجائحه طبعا الموضوع اختلف وانتقلت
الارقام الى مستويات قياسيه نود ان نعرف
يعني ما الذي خلاصهم اليه في ما يخص العنف
الاسري نحن نتحدث ايضا
بعض حالاته في همم الفيلم الذي رصدناه
الليله ما الفرق بين الاثنين اولا وما
الذي خلصتهم اليه في هذا الاستطلاع
نعم شكرا على الاستضافه
العنف الاسري هو مشكله مزمنه وحرجه
بمنطقتنا وحتى من قبل الجائحه كورونا فمثل
ما ذكرته بالتقرير نحو 15% من الاسر
بالمنطقه ابلغت انه
همم
باستطلاعنا انه فيه يتعرضون للعنف الاسري
وبطبع هذه النسب تختلف من بلد الى اخر
فالنسبه عاليه نسبيا في اليمن 26% والمغرب
25% وفي مصر همم 23% وابناها بالاردن
ولبنان وتونس 6% مثل ما قال الدكتور اكيد
هيدا همم
المعلنه والنسبه يمكن همم اكيد اكبر بكثير
بس همم النساء اغلبهم ما بيبلغوا عن
هالموضوع وكان ملفت لانه
ذكور ايضا يتعرضون لل- همم العنف
الاغلب هذه النسب تعود للاطفال والصبيان
من من الذكور وكانت نسبه عليها الاردن 89%
والجزائر 84% والعراق وليبيا 83
السيده اسيل فقط حتى نوضح هذه النقطه
الملفده حقيقه في المجتمعتنا ان يتعرض
الذكور ايضا عنف اسري على يد من يكون عاده
مثل هذا العنف
همم استطلاعنا ما بنسال على على يد مين بس
نسال مين هن الضحايا بهذا العنز فمعنى هذه
المعلومه همم
اذا كانوا اطفال يعني على احد افراد
العائله الاب او الام بده يكون يعني همم
وكمان هذا السؤال سيده اسيل عفوا حتى فقط
نشرح للمشاهد الكريم اسال هذا السؤال لانه
عاده في المؤسسه الزوجيه العنف ضد الزوجه
يكون من همم الزوج هل يعقل ان تكون
مستويات عنف على الزوج من قبل الزوجه مثلا
انها حالات شاذه في المجتمعاتنا
بعتقد انه هذه الحالات هاي حالات شاذه
بمجتماعاتنا على الارجح انه هن النسبه
العالي من الذكور هي تعود للصبيان
والاطفال
خطره جدا لانه بعدين بتصير يعني 1 يكبروا
هاللصبيان ممكن يهمني يصيروا يعدوا الاذى
همم اما نساهم زوجاتهم او لاطفالهم فمن
هيك مهم كثير يتعالج الموضوع والتركيز على
العنف الاسر ضد الاطفال ايضا بالاضافه لا
طبعا العنف ضد النساء همم اما بالنسبه
للنساء فالنسبه ده طبعا كانت عاليه جدا
همم وخاصه في لبنان 82% من النساء همم
يتعرضنا للعنف في الاسر اللي يوجد فيها
همم سوري
والنسبه عاليه ايضا بمصر 72% بالمغرب 71%
همم اما الاسباب مثل ما ذكرته الاسباب
عديده
مط مطرات
يعني الجميع للاسف هو موضوع مسكوت عن
تبليغ عنها لكن الجميع يعرف اسبابه
المتشعبه والمتعدده بدءا من الاسره الى
مجتمعات برمتها اسباب اقتصادها مثل ما
ذكرنا سياسيه اجتماعيه وغيرها سؤالنا
وانتم قد اجريتم العديد من الدراسات سيده
اسيل نود ان نشرح قليلا هذه المجتمعات هل
بالضروره المجتمعات ربما المجتمعات
الارياف يزيد او ينقص عن المجتمعات المدن
هل التعليم يلعب دورا ايضا هل الحاله
الاقتصاديه تلعب دورا ما الذي يمكن ان نصل
اليه همم كحقائق فيما يخص هذا الموضوع
بالنسبه للمناطق بحسب استطلاعاتنا ببين
انه في دول يمكن المناطق الريفيه فيها
اكثر نسبه عنف اسري اما في دول ثانيه
بالمناطق المدنيه يوجد فيها ما في ما في
قاعده لهذا الموضوع
بمنطقه الدول العربيه اما السبب الرئيسي
ذكرت اذا الموضوع له علاقه بالوضع
الاجتماعي او الاقتصاد او حتى الوضع الصحي
هلا في خلال ازمه كرونه يمكن كلها الاسباب
ممكن تزيد من
التوترات
بالمنزل والضغطات العائليه انما هذه فكره
خاطئه انه هذه الاسباب الخارجيه هي اللي
بتقدم لحدوث العنف الاسري وانه المعنف همم
ليس له همم الاراده بالسيطره على هذه
المشاكل
الخارجيه اللي عم تؤدي الى هذا العنف سبب
الرئيسي والج اللي هالموضوع هو عدم
المساواه بين المراه والرجل والفكره
النمطيه للمراه وهمم العنف لازم نعتبره
انه هو عمل فرد يقوم به المعنف بارادته
همم بطريقه اسلوب تعامله مع افراد العائله
همم بس همم بموضوع همم الوضع الاقتصادي
همم
ممكن يكون في نسبه اعلى ل همم العنف في
ال- همم العائلات اللي من همم من همم
مستوى همم
الارقام نعم السيده
وضعهن المعيشه والفقر هي الي علاقه اكثر
بال- بالتعليم وجدنا من خلال همم
استطلاعاتنا وخاصه للفتيات مشان هيك كثير
مهم فكره انه الفتيات يحصل على درجه
ومش بس مدرسه يوصل لحتى لدرجه عاليه من
التعليم حيث وجدنا انه همم بالطبع مستوى
همم حياته الاقتصاديه بيتحسن ممكن يقدروا
يظهروا من المكان اللي عايشين فيه الماوى
يلي فيه عنف وبيوصلوا على استقلاليه
ساعود اليك سيده اسيل اعود اليك لا زال
لدينا مبتسم من الوقت وسنن طبعا بفرصه
اخرى موضوع هذه الحلقه في الواقعه فاضيه
باهتمام على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي ركزت
اغلب المشاركات على اهميه تقويه الوازعه
الديني مثل ما كان يقول ضيفنا الكريم وحتى
التربوي للحد من العنف الاسري وجود قوانين
رادعه في مشاركه المسجله اكدت ريما البحر
وهي رئيسه جمعيه بصمه خير الفلسطينيه اكدت
على ضروره التوعيه بمخاطر العنف الاسري
للحفاظ على السلم الاهلي في المجتمعات
العربيه وحددت انواعها العنف الاسري نتابع
معا
طرق العنف المجتمعي والاسري تحديدا كثيره
ممكن ان تكون بالكلمه بالنظره ليس فقط
بتدارك الايدي كما هو مفهوم للكثير لذلك
نطالب المؤسسات التي تعنى في الجوانب
الاسريه والحقوقيه بان تكفف من حملاتها
الت
وعويه ولهذه الظاهره للحد منها وللمحافظه
قدر الامكان على السلم الاهلي في
المجتمعات العربيات طبعا نحن نتحدث عن
المجتمعات العربيه لكن اود ان اعود مره
اخرى لدكتور حسين ونود مقارنه بين صح همم
التعبير لا طالما وصلنا العربي بانه عنيف
هل هذه الدرجات من العنف ان كورنت
المجتمعات العربيه والدول العربيه بالدول
الغربيه هي بالفعل اكبر ما الذي تقوله
الارقام والدراسات بهذا الخصوص
نعم المجتمعات العربيه اكثر
لعده اسباب يعني هي الطابع الذكوري للاسف
الشديد هو الغالب يبدا من اولا من تفضيل
انجاب الذكر واثنين التركيز على الذكر بكل
شيء يعني سواء كان بالتعليم سواء كان
بالعمل سوء وان كان باعطاء الخيارات
المتعدده لهم وايضا كمان في قضيه مهمه انه
دائما
ربط ربط الفتاه بالذكر الانثى بالذكر حتى
لو المراه لو تحدثت كلاما صادقا لو عملت
عملا سليما او عملا ايه خلينا احكي همم
بيرفع مكانه الرجل بيقولوا عنها اخت
الرجال مثلا الامثال والحكم للاسف الشديد
التي قيلت في المجتمعات العربيه كلياتها
للاسف تنتقص من مكانه المراه وهذا خطا ان
يتم تداولها لهذا السبب سلطنا على الذكر
اكثر من
المراه وهذا لا يجب ان نبعده نهائيا
للثقافه الشعبيه في قضيه مهم اسمحي لي
اركز عليها في المجتمعات العربيه اللي هو
زواج الاقارب زواج الاقارب بيخلي دائما
العنف الاسري في محيط الاسره لماذا لانها
تتزوج ابن عمها او بنت عمها ابن خالته من
قراءه اقارب من الدرجه الاولى تخيلي يصل
الى 60% من من الحالات الزواج مثلا في
السودان في المنطقه العربيه ممكن في دول
الخليج العربي من 54
في الاردن 28 في كل المجتمعات العربيه
الصلات القرابيه تحفظ اي اا حاله عنف
وتصلحها ذاتيا ولا
اسره كما ذكرت وتصبح الاسره التي يفترض ان
تكون صمام الامان هي للاسف الشديد ايضا
التي تتستر او العائله الان في هذه الحاله
وهي يعني الدائره همم الاكبر دكتور حسين
نحن نتحدث عن عنف المراه لكن هناك عنف لا
يقل اهميه العنف ضد الاطفال في الاردن حيث
تكلمنا انت مثلا كشفت دراسه عن تعرض معظم
الاطفال العنف الجسدي على نحو واسع في
البلاد وهو الحال نفسه ما فيش احد احسن من
حدا في مختلف وتقريبا كل المجتمعات
العربيه كيف كيف يفسر هذا العنف ضد
الاطفال وقد تبعنا قصه نائل في بدايته
وكيف كان يتعرض ليس فقط للتعنيف من والده
لكن تعذيب ومنهج هو واخواته
هذا للاسف يعني ناجم عن فشل في التربيه
منذ الصغر
وهذا تقليد اعمى للاب لا سلطه الاب التي
يمارسها على الاطفال في الاسره لهذا السبب
احنا بنقول دائما انه الاباء يجب عليهم ان
يفرقوا ما بين التربيه وما بين الضرب
والعنف التربيه وتعديل السلوك 40 طريقه
ممكن عندك تستخدم انت طرق كثيره جدا
لتعديل سلوك ابنك ممكن تستخدم مثلا على
سبيل المثال تعديل السلوك الانساني
الهدايا النصيحه الموعظه الارشاد ولكن
تقليد شخصيه الاب للاسف بعد الزواج هذا هو
الذي يسيطر على
الابناء بعد ما انهم
يتزوجوا وايضا
يقدون بانه كان الاب سلوكه صحيحا هاي قضيه
قضيه ثانيه ان الاطفال ما بقدروا يدافعوا
عن انفسهم للاسف نعم وايضا كمان لا يستطيع
لا يستطيع الطفل انه يرفع صوته او انه
يوبق ابوه او انه يرد الضربه بضربه مثلا
هون وخاصه الاطفال فهنا يتمادى الاباء
وانا باقول للاباء كل الاباء الان اللي
بيسمعوني عبر قناه الجزيره وعمل هذا
البرنامج الطيب ما بقول لهم يا معشر
الاباء يا معشر الرجال
ايها الاخوه
انا بناشدكم بالله رفقا بابنائكم استوصوا
بالنساء خيرا هذا الرسول عليه الصلاه
والسلام الان احدى المشاهدات قالت انه
تعزيز الواسع الديني انا بدي احكي لهم
قضيه كيف نعزز الوازع الديني كالتالي احنا
عندنا
شخصيه الرسول عليه الصلاه والسلام سيدنا
محمد كان دائما ابتسام كان يحب الاطفال
حتى اي من الديانات على وجه البسيطه اعود
مره اخرى للسيده اسيل العلائي كما يخص
الاطفال وهي قصص ماساويه للاسف هناك من
الاباء وحتى من الامهات من ليسوا 80 على
اطفالهم ما الذي تقوله الارقام معدلات
العنف الممارسه تجاه متى على الاسباب هذا
العنف الذي يكون ممارسا ضد الاطفال
ان
الافعى العنف ضد الاطفال انما الارقام
لاننا اياها بشكل عام عن العنف الاسري
فممكن يكون موجه للاطفال او الذكور او لا
للنساء ما عندي ارقام عن هالموضوع اذا
دعينا نتوقف الان همم مع بعض المشاركات في
الواقع الفنانه السوريه رشا رزق دعت
الناشطات النسويات في المجال العام الى
العمل على اصدار قوانين لحمايه النساء من
العنف المنزلي نتابع ما الذي قالته رشا في
الواقع ونعود
في مجتمع ذكوري
يعاقب الضحيه ولا يعاقب المعلم
نحن بحاجه الى اطار قضائي يجرم هذا نوع من
الممارسات المجتمعيه الخاطئه ويصححها
ويحمي الامراه والطفله ايضا والطفلات بان
في ذلك حمايه للاسره وحمايه للاطفال ايضا
طالبنا بحقوقكن ايتها النساء لان كنا ان
لم تطالبنا بها لن يطالب بها احد اخر ان
لم تكن لنا فلن طالب بها من اجل بناتنا
في الواقع المدونه والمخرجه الاء حمدان
دعت الى توسيع نطاق النشر والحديث على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي عما تكابده
النساء والفتيات المعنفات في عالمنا
العربي لزياده الوعي بالعنف الاسري نتابعه
للاسف ارتفعت خلال فتره رائحه الكرونه
نسبه العنف ضد المراه 33%
وصار لازم انه نساء يعلى صوتها على وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي لا تعرف انه ما في عيب
ولا حرج من انك توقفي بوجه العنف سواء كان
في بيتك زوجي يعني مع زوجك او في بيتك مع
اهلك او اخوك او والدتك كل ما انتشرت
الاساس اكثر كل ما المراه المعنفه عرفت
اكثر انه اللي بيصير معها مرفوض بامكانها
تشتكي وحقها ممكن تاخذه والحياه اللي
بتنتظرها خارج البيت العنف افضل للاسف مش
كل القوانين في دولنا العربيه منصفه
للمراه المعنفه احيانا في قوانين ما بتجرم
الرجل في حال عن نفس زوجته او بنته الا في
حال تسبب بيعها دائما
تبعنا اذا هذه المشاركه واود ان نعود مره
اخرى السيده اسيل يعني ضروره الابلاغ
ضروره الحديث عن هذا الموضوع تبعنا ذلك
ايضا في قصتنا الليله نائل قال بانه اختار
ان يتحدث لنشر الوعي باعتقادك الى اي مدى
الاسهام عن الابلاغ عن ما يتعرض له او
تتعرض له هذه الفئات الاكثر ضعفا اهميه
الابلاغ عن ما يتعرضون له بالنسبه لمعالجه
هذه المشكله والمساعده ايضا في ان همم
تطبق القوانين بالشكل الصحيح ومن ثم يؤخذ
حق الذي وقع عليه العنف
ما في شك انه مهم كثير يتم الابلاغ عن
حالات العنف الاسري او العنف ضد النساء
انما من خلال نتائج استطلاعاتنا اييه
وجدنا انه
اغلب النساء بالمنطقه العربيه
يبلغون فقط افراد العائله على حصول او
تعرضا للعنف الاسري حوالي 88% من النساء
بالمنطقه يلجانا الى الاقارب همم فقط
بنسبه همم 12% من النساء يلجانا ويقدموا
ويقدم لنا شكوى للشرطه المحليه ما عدا
لبنان 49%
نحن نعلم بان هناك منظمات تنشط بشكل رائع
في هذا المجال في مختلف الدول العربيه
الطبع اكيد شغلهم كثير مهم بس بدي اقول لك
في 6% فقط يرجعنا للمستشفيات وبحسب نتائج
استطلاعاتنا بسنتيه 2018/2019
بالكييد ولا امراه تلجا الى منظمات
المجتمع المدني يعني تعنى بمساعده النساء
انا مامون مش موجودين انه ما عم يعملوا
شغلوا حتى يمكن زيت شغلهم هلا خلال فتره
كرونه انما النسبه بالمقارنه مع النساء
اللي بيعتبروا انه العنف الاسري ما زال
مساله عائليه خاصه بعدها هي الاغلبيه هون
تكمل المشكله اذا ما غيرنا همم نمط
التفكير والسلطات العربيه ما همم اعتبرت
انه العنف الاسري هو مساله صحه عامه همم
للاسف سيبقى الموضوع الموضوع غير معالج
بشكل فعال
السيده اسيل التي تشين الى نقطه مهمه انت
كتبتي مقال حول هذا الموضوع اعت في النجاح
كورونا التي للاسف كما ذكرنا رفعت مستويات
العنف وفي العالم يا اجمع الى مستويات
كبيره همم جدا هذه الجائحه اعتبرت انها
توفر فرصه لتحويل العنف الاسري من شان خاص
الى قضيه عامه سمعنا ايضا شهاده الامين
العام للامم المتحده في الميناء الليله
حول الموضوع لكن كيف تصورك كيف هو تصورك
لهذا الموضوع كيف يمكن ان تتحول فعلا الى
قضيه راي عام او قضيه نعم
على المدى القريب لازم السلطات التعلم من
هالموضوع بانه مثلا الصحه عامه وليست
مساله عائليه ممكن الغد النظر عنها بطريقه
هي انه يكون شكله العلاقات ما بين الشرطه
والمستشفيات والتشريعات حتى الاعلام لا
يضووا على هالموضوع من اجل تامين همم
مساعد فوريه للضحايا العنف الاسري
والتمكين النساء بعد طلبا المساعده انما
على المدى البعيد اذا ما قمنا بتوعيه
المجتمع وتوعيه المشرعين وال همم الشرطه
والفاعلين بهالموضوع حتى توعيه الاعلام
والمنتجين المسلسلات حتى والفنانين حتى
يغيروا الصوره النبطيه للمراه
التعزيز فكره المساواه بين المراه والرجل
للاسف همم العنف الاسري سيبقى موجود
والنساء لن تثق بالحلول المطروحه حاليا
همم من من السلطات وهتبقى بس ترجع اسرتها
وشفنا النتيجه انه ما في ما في مساعده
فعليه بهالموضوع والجاني والمعنف سيبقى حر
طليق يقوم بافعاله الشنيعه
لاتحول الى الدكتور حسين بهذا الخصوص
الكثير من الدول اصدرت او هي في طريق
اصدار تشريعات وقوانين فيما يخص العنف
الاسري لكن هذا لم يوقف العنف ويبدو انه
لن يفعل ما الذي ينقص حتى تجد هذه
التشريحات طريقها للتطبيق ان صح التعبير
المجتمع
المجتمع هو الذي
خليني احكي هو الذي يعيق تنفيذ هذه
القوانين والانظمه اللي موجود الان في كل
اقطار الوطن العربي لماذا المجتمع لانه
يتدخل حتى لو
راحت وقدمت شكوى الان تتم المصالحه عند
المراكز الامن
وايضا اذا لم تتم المصالحه اذا راحت وانا
بقول لك اذا ذهبت وهنا المنطقه العربيه
فقط فقط ممكن قد تكون لبنان 49% النساء
افصحنا بانهن ممكن يقدم من شكاوي ومصر 16%
اما باقي الدول كلها 12 و 6% واربعه في
المئه ما راح يقدمه شكاوي لماذا لانه
يحسبنا حساب ما بعد الشكوى ما بعد الشكوى
الخوف على الاسره على مستقبل سرعه على
مستقبل الاولاد وما هو البديل الفقر
116 مليون فقير في الوطن العربي 38 مليون
جائع في الوطن العربي اين ستذهب المراه ما
هو البديل ما هو الحل الحل اقتصادي كيف
هنا المراه لماذا تصمت المراه لماذا تبلع
تبلع همم العنف ولا تذهب لتقديم الشكوى
لماذا لانها تخاف من الطلاق تخاف من تشرد
الاولاد الرجل يمتلك قضيتين خطيرات وخليني
احكي لك اياهم القضيه الاولى حق الزواج
الفوري والسريعه الرجل هو الذي يطلبه
العروس في الوطن العربي البنت ما بتطلب
عريس هاي واحده اثنين الرجل يمتلك حق
الطلاق الفوري والسريع فهنا الخوف من هذه
الثقافه الذكوريه هي التي تعزز العنف الاس
للاسف تعزيز العنف الاسري دكتور حسين اريد
ان اختم معك وفي اقل من دقيقه لو تكرمت
هذا المسكوت عنه ماذا عن تداعياته الان
على مجتمعاتنا العربيه
تداعيات نفسيه اقتصاديه
اجتماعيه دينيه تنشئه اجيال للاسف الشديد
تتمسك بتقليد الاباء والامهات فاحنا بنقول
لهم الان علي كل مؤسسات المجتمع المدني كل
المؤسسات الضبط الاجتماعي غير الرسم
والرسمي انا بقول عن المسجد الجامعه
المدرسه
الجيره العلاقات الاجتماعيه
كلها الاعلام لازم نوعي بخطوره ال- ال-
الاضرار الناجمه عن العنف الاسري وان نقول
للرجال وان نقول لهم
استبدلوا الضرب بالابتسامه بالمحبه
بالموده اسعدوا ابنائكم
شديده تواضع
جديد تواضع اتمنى ان تجد بيتكم
نتمنى ان يقتدوا مثل ما ذكرت بالرسول
الكريم عليه الصلاه والسلام ولعل في هذا
اكبر قدوه اشكرك جزيل شكرا اتمنى ان تجد
كلماتك الاذان الصاغيه والضمائر الحيه
ايضا اشكرك جزيلا الشكر الدكتور حسين
الخزاعي البروفيسور المتخصص في ااا
علم الاجتماع كنت معنا من عمان كما اشكر
جزيل الشكر اسيل العلائي لمديره قسم
التواصل والاعلام في جبال في شبكه
البارومه العربيه البحثيه في جامعه
الناشطه في الشؤون الجندريه كنت معنا من
فيرجينيا في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ختامه حلقتنا هذه نعود ونلقاكم باذن الله
هل اثنا القادم بقيه لقصه جديده السلام
عليكم
[موسيقى]